[Music]
on this episode of travel chairs I'm
taking Joe to Jacob's Well one of the
most beautiful swimming holes in Texas
and I'm here at Round Rock we're gonna
learn how to harvest honey come join us
on our adventures on this episode of
Travel tears
welcome to travel chairs I'm Caroline
and I'm Joe and today we are in Austin
Texas Austin is a paradise for lovers of
food music and nature so are you excited
I'm so excited
here's your clue uh-huh clue number one
get ready to jump
I'm ready for jumping all right you know
the drill this is gonna be perfect for
Joe he's not usually the most outdoorsy
person but this swimming hole is going
to take his breath away you are facing
the activity and take off your blindfold
I got here oh my god what is this it is
Austin's most famous swimming hole and
we're gonna go diving into it
[Music]
Jacob's Well started out as a local kind
of secret swimming hole for the Wimberly
in Wood Creek residents somewhere around
2015 word got out but there's this
remarkable spring you can come jump in
that's unlike any other spring in Texas
when folks are first getting ready to
jump in they stand there and they feel a
legitimate terror so when you're here
you got to challenge yourself to do
something you're afraid of that's not
scary looking from this angle I jump
land in the water
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Joe how'd you like diving into
Jacobs well Caroline I loved it there
was so much fun it was an incredible
experience I can see why you like
swimming holes so much now I definitely
want to go to more swimming holes thank
you so much for taking me here and now
it's time for your clue
[Music]
get ready for a sweet adventure I like
the side of that okay III honestly think
we're gonna eat like a giant dessert Oh
Connexus we're gonna have good food and
it's gonna be big press your finger see
try and just get it all right
see that oh nothing just kind of gravel
oh oh good try trust me it's a honey
that's right take up that longing take
off your blindfold because today we are
going to learn how to harvest oh my god
this guy over here
[Music]
honey's really important to Texas and
I'm excited to take care line here
deepen her appreciation for bees zip it
up whenever this part of the country was
being settled Texas had the largest
honey flows of anywhere outside of the
Caribbean area and we're also the first
in the last tiny flow of all of North
America
and oh wow so they're turning the pollen
into bread mm-hmm and they're turning
the nectar into honey and they're
producing honey
24/7 always I've never looked at it be
disclose without flinching or running
away I'm really gaining a lot of
confidence yeah all right Caroline you
got this
pick up that frame cool oh that's a good
one
what's the next step well let's go back
to the honey house and taste that honey
that we just harvested let's do it we're
going to harvest those frames that we
just took out of the Beehive so you're
going to just take off the surface layer
here you don't want to go in very deep
[Music]
people come to router County because we
have one of the best local honey's that
you can buy it's a blended honey from
all of our various hives throughout the
area
so this is our Round Rock honey this is
our original we've been doing this for
over 15 years out so this is similar the
one that we were harvesting today yes
Joe thank you so much for taking me here
my pleasure as matter of fact I think
I'm taking a bottle home with me I think
I am you know everyone thinks of Austin
is just being about barbecue and live
music but there's so many other great
things to explore in the city we don't
into Jacob swell we harvested some honey
it's been quite the day moment of truth
how to do my rating Joe you were so
courageous going into Jacob's Well and
you jumped three times in front of a
huge crowd and because of that you are
getting 5 out of 5 so yes I get a 5 the
coveted five-star rating you have quite
the audience out there alright so how
did I do my beekeeping challenge
Caroline I can tell them we got that you
were totally nervous but you put on the
suit
it got up on that hive you even picked
up the little thing there with the
beasts hanging from it I was so
impressed I'm giving you four out of
five all right all right I'll take it I
like a four out of five you know what
Joe Congrats on your five stars we're
celebrating Austin was incredible I
can't wait to see what Santa Fe has in
store for us yeah me too
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]